it's his first start of the year in his
ten and two thirds innings gooby a
couple of earned runs overall allowed he
struck out more than a batter per inning
of work those are some pretty sparkling
numbers give us some go-to's my go-to
have success against him today is he got
to power his secondary pitches 278
versus his secondary pitch that's his
curve and change up with a home run and
lay off those elevated four-seam
fastballs he has 10 strikeouts with his
fastball upstairs so far this year and
he is on with a one-hour walk-in
the red-hot mike trout will be the next
batter and this one it's hit well into
center field that ball's traveling deep
it's trout of here
hits it out the dead center field
mike trout with a two-run homer angels
have a two-nothing lead
trout gets a fastball this one's right
over the heart of the plate and just
turns hits it out dead center
and when shohei steals the base you have
the option to kind of pitch around trout
as hot as he is and as much damage he's
done to seattle in his career they elect
not to they come after him with the
fastball and it's not down in the zone
it's actually on the upper side of the
strike zone and trout gets to it
and puts the angels up two nothing jared
walsh will be the next spatter and this
is lifted in the air and hit well out
into left center field it's out by the
wall and it's out of here
another first inning homer for the
angels and now it's three to nothing
walsh goes the opposite way
[Applause]
and jared wallace checking in early
another rbi for jared walsh number 19 on
the season as far as rbi's home run
number five a tremendous at-bat this is
a change-up first pitch curveball second
pitch change-up on the outer half stays
right on it and drives it out into left
field out into the angels bullpen
griffin canning is on the mound canning
goes to work 15 innings so far this year
an era that is over eight in those 15
innings there have been plenty of
strikeouts 17 of them he's worked once
out of the pen as well and he got him to
chase one another slider it looked like
that was out of the strike zone but he
struck him out so two are gone couple of
easy outs and
we're kind of wondering the angels put
the three spot on the board for canning
that has to take a little pressure off
him going into the bottom of the first
inning
joe hey is the batter he's walked stolen
a base and scored a run and he is
stepping up with a couple of runners in
scoring position second and third one
out and shohei hits one sharply but it's
stopped by the first baseman and the
only play will be first base as france
thought about throwing home decides just
to put the foot on the bag to get ohtani
and scoring on that hard-hit ground out
from third base will be iglesias it's
four nothing angels trout put on and now
anthony rendon will be stepping up
drives that one toward the gap in left
center field he hit that one hard it is
down
one angel come on down here comes mike
trout he flies toward the plate he is in
there
anthony rendon
gets it dark
three in the first three here in the
second a six nothing lead the pitch on
walsh at ball is absolutely clobbered in
the right center field it's out of here
a home run
and a couple more to the total right now
it is eight nothing angels
for jared walsh his second home run of
the game
first hat back got a changeup on the
outer half and hit it out in left field
this one a fastball and boy he squares
everything up the timing is perfect jp
crawford at the plate he swings at the
first one fouls that one off murphy
holds the pitch swung on line drives him
again right center field that's going to
get down murphy the second he's motoring
his sliding attempt by walsh to pick it
up murphy's coming around third here's
the throw to the plate not in time
mariners on the board
rbi double jp crawford we got an 8-1
ball game here in the third
jp's been doing some damage there at the
bottom of the order last 20 ball games
jp is banning 290 and driving in some
runs and he's seeing a lot of pitches
he's getting deep into counts there's a
pitch that comes back over the plate
middle in and he hits it hard into the
gap in right center field to drive in
murphy for his eighth rbi of the year
crawford a nice swing again
i think that's the second time this
season we've seen murph score from first
very impressive
these catchers union representatives are
very proud
here's rendon batting now this is hit
high in the air and it's hit well out
into left field tremelo goes back it's
out of here it's a home run
the angels fourth homer in four innings
and that's a two-run shot for
brandon his second homer of the season
and he's already driven in four runs
tonight angels add-on it's 10-1
[Music]
we're talking about the timing of rindon
starts to come to appear the last three
games he's starting to drive runs in
starting to square some balls up
this is an absolute hanging breaking
ball curveball that stays right in the
heart of the plate anthony rindon
not fooled whatsoever and he takes the
ball with the mariners having the bases
loaded and two outs here in the bottom
of the eighth inning by myers and the
pitch the moore's swinging a line
driving to center field for a base hit
here comes hagerty underscore lewis
ronnie third heading home he's going to
score trouble for the ball to throw to
third is cut off by iglesias dylan moore
with a two out two run single and it's
now the angels 10 and the mariners three
more with a base hit into center field
and two runs are in with two outs here
in the bottom of the eighth
10-3 ball game
one on and one away crawford's second
hit of the night he's two for three
swinging a drive deep to left field by
hannigan going and going and goodbye
baseball it slams into the stairway and
straight away left high above the angel
bullpen mitch haniger with his sabbath
home run of the season
a two-run blast here in the bottom of
the ninth and it's now the angels ten
and the mariners five
canada jumping on the first offering
from ben rowan and i'm telling you he
crushed it
the sound
just
punctuated everything
that was a pitch oh my goodness center
cut
wow
he got all 108 stitches so the mariners
are down to their final out
batter is haggarty
called third strike to end the ball game
angels come away with the victory
tonight they double up the mariners at
t-mobile park